hello everyone and welcome to a
wonderful game from round four of this
year's fed Grand Swiss it is Hans smoken
Iman versus rard Rapport and um it's uh
well it's quite a brutal game but also I
wanted to mention that for those of you
who don't know uh reard rort is mainly
the reason why the game between hunts
and Magnus happened last year in the
singfield cup you know the the
controversial one where you know they
went to court and everything uh it was
uh rard rapot who was supposed to be
playing in the event but he withdrew
from the tournament and that's why Hans
nean was placed in the tournament so
interesting stuff and now they face each
other in a classical game over the board
so let's check it out uh Hans has the
white pieces and he opens with D4 uh we
have D5 by U rard we have Pawn to C4 C6
going for the SLO defense Knight F3
Knight to F6 and now Pawn to E3 the
quiet variation we have Bishop to F5 the
shop defense uh and the Knight to C3
Pawn to E6 and Knight H4 going after the
bishop so we've seen this many times uh
nothing new here Bishop to G6 and queen
to B3 putting pressure on the B7 Pawn so
you have to defend it Queen to C7
sometimes Queen to B6 is also played but
Queen to C7 is the more common idea
Bishop to D2 and now Knight to E4
putting pressure on the on the bishop
and Knight here so Knight captures
Bishop captures and C captures on D5 and
there are a couple of ways you could
capture uh you could recapture with C
you could recapture with E Capture on D5
Bishop captures on D5 or you could even
maybe play Bishop to E7 just ignore the
pawn here and attack the undefended
Knight but uh then you get D6 in now if
Queen captures the B7 Pawn hangs so the
bishop has to capture and now you
continue development Bishop to D3 let's
say Bishop to D5 and queen to C2 and we
get to this position where the queen and
the bishop are on a very natural are on
very natural squares the Knight will
come back to F3 at some point and
everything is perfectly fine but rapper
decided to play Bishop captures on D5
right away and we get a very similar
position now Queen to C2 is the move
that's uh always been played here but
here we have Bishop to C4 and it is now
as of move 11 that we have a completely
new game so okay Bishop to E7 attacks
the Knight Knight back to F3 and Knight
to D7 now uh we have Queen back to C2
and now Knight to F6 so both players
just putting pieces on their uh
belonging squares Bishop to D3 and now
uh you have to be careful you might uh
you know think about okay let's just
Castle here to safety and then think
about our you know game plan where to
develop pieces but then E4 just blunders
the bishop on D5 so you have to handle
the bishop with care Bishop captures an
F3 uh this does mess up Hunt's Pawn
structure but it also does give hunt the
advantage of the bishop pair or maybe
it's not going to be an advantage it's
the potential to have the advantage of
the bishop pair so G captures on F3 and
now Knight to D5 an excellent Square for
the Knight and the Hunts will have to
figure out does he want to have this
setup with F3 E4 and the D4 or does he
want to have the set up with D4 E3 and
this Pawn to F4 so Pawn to A3 first
stopping Knight to B4 as he does want to
keep his Bishop pair if he allowed
Knight to B4 he would have to give up
one of the Bishops and now Queens side
castles we have Queen side castles and
pawn to G5 now stopping Pawn to F4 and
also Pawn to H4 uh we have King to B1
and also King to B8 we have Rook to C1
uh and now just Pawn to H6 we have Queen
to B3 and now even King to A8 you don't
want the King on B8 if um some tactics
uh are possible uh Bishop to C4 by hunts
we have Queen to D7 and now Bishop to A5
attacking The Rook here Rook to C8 and
now Rook H to D1 we have Bishop to d8
trying to trade off the uh the Bishops
uh but Hans of course wants to keep his
Bishop Bishop to E1 Bishop to C7 and now
Pawn to H3 as the pawn was attacked here
so Rook H to d8 and now Pawn to A4 now
hun says all right I don't really have
ways of pushing anything here but I can
push the a pawn maybe if I can get a
pawn to A5 and A6 I can open up the
black King's position at least a little
bit so Bishop back to B8 and now Bishop
to A5 repeating once again uh Bishop to
C7 and now Bishop back to D2 We have
Bishop back to B8 and now King to A1 one
uh Queen to E7 and now Bishop to A5
attacking The Rook again Bishop to C7
and Bishop back to D2 We have Bishop
back to B8 and now Rook to C2 so now
hunts with some ideas of doubling up on
the C file uh Bishop to D6 and again
Bishop to A5 so if if if nothing else
you are getting closer to that move 40
uh but also you are checking if um if
Rapport really wants to repeat moves and
here interestingly he doesn't go back
with Bishop to C7 he actually plays Rook
to E8 and okay now Hans plays Pawn to E4
challenges the Knight and now you sort
of have to choose between continuing the
game and the draw uh because if you go
uh Bishop to B4 then it's uh much much
easier to conclude this game to to sort
of a peaceful resolution let's say he
captures on D5 Bishop captures on A5 now
D captures on E6 F captures on E6 and
okay you will win the uh E Pawn but
Bishops are of opposite color so not
much um that you will be able to do here
let's say queen B4 Queen captures Bishop
captures Rook captures on E6 you trade
everything off and okay it's uh you will
move the Rook somewhere let's say Rook
to f8 the doubl pawns are weak so um you
you should have all the
uh all that you need to actually not
lose this game and to get a nice draw
but he wanted more he played Knight to
F4 now puts pressure on the H3 pawn and
Bishop back to to F1 with have Bishop to
C7 offering a trade and Bishop to B4 now
attacking the queen uh Queen to D7 again
not repeating with Bishop to D6 it seems
that Rapport also wants more from this
game and now Hans just continues pushing
Pawn to A5 uh Pawn to A6 and now Bishop
to C5 and now already you can uh feel
what Hunt is dreaming of uh he he wants
to give up the A5 pawn and this is uh
not great for black if black captures
the pawn then it's going to be terrible
uh to give you an example if Bishop
captures on A5 then the idea is Queen A4
you attack the bishop and now let's say
you retreat with the bishop it's a
pretty straightforward idea Bishop
captures on A6 and after B captures
Queen captures with check and after King
B8 just Rook C3 and Rook B3 will end the
game even if you play Queen B7 to stop
Rook B3 Rook B3 still wins the game
because now you lose the queen or you
capture and then Queen to A7 is
Checkmate so you can't um move the
bishop back you're going to have to
place something like Queen to C7 and
then the real idea behind the pawn the a
pawn sacrifice is Pawn to B4 uh Bishop
to B6 and now Rook A2 just piling up
everything against that black king king
to B8 now Rook to B1 and uh you well you
you might be able to hold this but it is
very unlikely even with engine perfect
play you you probably lose this with
black so that's hans's idea behind the
pawn sacrifice rard did not capture it
he played Rook C to d8 and now Hans
doubles up on the C file Rook D to C1
and now again it's something of uh
rapports nature that probably made him
do this you could still play some some
moves like F6 you could play Rook to B8
just repeat moves and uh wait to see
what Hans does for Hans to move forward
uh but Rapport actually captures the
pawn bishop captures on A5 and now
what's the difference between The Rook
being on C8 in the line that we've shown
and The Rook now being on d8 is The Rook
on d8 somehow more powerful than in the
line that we've shown well hun says all
right show me why the Rook on d8 is so
much better than the Rook on C8 uh so
Queen to A4 Queen to C7 and now B4
lacking the line that we've discussed
the bishop to B6 but now uh that The
Rook is not here helping out with the
defense of the C Pawn Hans no longer has
to prepare the attack with something
like Rook to A2 and Rook to B1 Hans can
go for Bishop captures on A6 right away
and this is what he does the point is
now that if B captures you throw in a
bishop capture on B6 and after Queen
captures the pawn is not defended Rook
captures on C6 and black resigns that is
why Rook to d8 is the big difference
here now it doesn't matter if you even
if you give this one check King A2 and
you give one more check no more checks
next uh it's it's game over so after
Bishop captures on A6 raer is all right
I I I I feel you have something there he
plays King to B8 but now Rook to
A2 uh here Rook captures on D4 was
played trying to give up material in
order to survive the attack but now the
position is completely winning for hunts
feel free to pause the video and win the
game for hunts while I give you a couple
of
[Music]
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on uh uh
realizing the real weakness in Black's
position and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Bishop back
to B5 and this is the only Retreat of
the bishop that works and the reason why
works is because the C6 Pawn was
weakened uh yes that that is true so now
you cannot capture the bishop if you
capture the bishop of course it's mate
in one so you cannot play that you have
to play something else King to C8 of
course you have to start running away
with the King but now Bishop captures on
B6 Queen captures and Bishop captures on
C6 as you are attacking the C6 Square
sufficiently so of course you cannot
capture it otherwise you're going to
lose your queen Knight to D3 was Tried
by raer going after the rook and see one
that's undefended uh but now just Queen
to A8 with check King to C7 and Bishop
captures on E8 okay Knight captures on
C1 winning back some material and now
Rook to C2 with check King to D6 and now
you have to be very very careful if you
if you play Rook captures on C1 then you
allow the black king to escape so you
have to play something else Queen to B8
check the only move that wins and Hunt
play it the key is that you have to gain
control over the C7 Square in order to
achieve this Rook lift Rook to C7 and
promote your Rook to a full full grown
Pig so King to E7 Rook to C7 with check
and he was in this position on move 51
that rard rort resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
now that the king starts running it
doesn't matter as the F7 square is
covered so Rook captures an F7 check
King to G6 now you go for some uh disc
discoveries Rook to D7 check King F King
F6 E5 with check King to F5 Bishop to G6
with with check and now if you go down
the board then Rook to F7 is mate in one
uh compliments of the doubled Pawn on F2
and if you capture the bishop then the
queen is back into the attack Queen E8
check King to F5 Queen to F7 check King
captures on E5 and now Queen G7 check
King F4 and of course Rook to F7 or
queen to F6 doesn't really matter both
are Checkmate so rert of course saw this
and after Rook to C7 check he resigned
and another wonderful victory for Hans
smoken nean uh who is doing now in
incredibly well in the tournament and in
round five he will be playing on board
three facing none other than alira fuja
so we'll see what happens in in that one
uh so yeah once again really hope you
guys enjoyed it I would like to wish a
very happy birthday to Dino vodopia and
I would like to thank John gear Law
Office LLC Mario Milano the brutter on
Spotify and stepen mccan for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the Chess
World so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day